[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have revealed the
free games we'll be receiving as PS plus
subscribers for the month of July 2023.
all three of these games are
downloadable on Tuesday July 4th around
midday or whenever the store updates in
your country and it's a banger of a
month so let's do this Call of Duty
Black Ops cold war is top of the list on
both PS4 and PS5 releasing three years
ago this first person shooter takes us
back to the 1980s and the Cold War era
multiplayer wise things haven't really
changed over the years in Call of Duty
in a good way the shooting mechanics
feel as great as always and the suite of
cod game modes are as Bountiful as
always there are a few additions like
combined arms which plays more like a
battlefield match and of course the
iconic Zombies mode is here for the
uninitiated zombies is a survival mode
that pits hordes of Zombies against you
and your squad and then ramps up in
difficulty each round the single player
campaign of Cold War canonically fits in
between Black Ops 1 and 2 and becomes a
fantasy spy drum which flirts with the
ridiculous especially for the 1980s a
great feature on Playstation is on the
PS5 and the Dual sense controller as gun
recoil affects the vibration function
and each weapon handles differently as
the triggers resist differently to
different weapons my Pro tip is don't
ever use this in multiplayer modes the
offset in reaction time will be your
downfall it's not worth it Call of Duty
Black Ops Cold War reviews say it's a
7.8 out of 10. very nice so you've
probably seen the Alan Wake 2 trailers
and thought about playing the original
one well here it is Alan Wake remastered
a former XBox exclusive which follows
Thriller novelist Alan Wake as he
uncovers the mystery behind his wife's
disappearance although it's not a
full-fledged horror game it definitely
plays with the psychological thriller
movie tropes the game is even presented
as a TV show as Alan collects Clues from
his own novels gameplay is pretty simple
no need for skill trees or crafting here
it's simply about using your limited
Arsenal to survive from point A to point
B and constantly needing to find
batteries for your flashlight all DLC is
included in Alan Wake remastered
including bonus episodes and a really
cool voice over from the game's devs and
writers as you play overall a solid 7
out of 10 especially for a game that
released over a decade ago with a new
coat of paint on it if you do play this
get your phone out and scan the QR codes
finally endling Extinction is forever
released exactly one year ago endling is
another Survival game as we play as a
motherfox escaping a forest fire with
her Cubs this becomes the point of the
entire game to keep your Offspring safe
and cared for in what seems to be a
post-apocalyptic World in one scene a
human scavenger will take a pop from you
and it's up to you to get that little
one back over time we learn new skills
as we forage for food learning to track
Footprints and olders being both the
Hunter and the hunted running around
seven hours in length or about 14 for
those who are hunting for the Platinum
it's tough to find a review score on
Playstation so I'll use Nintendo World
instead they gave it an 8 out of 10 so
it's definitely worth your time so
that's it that's the month what are you
playing Alan Wake for me gotta prepare
for that second game and I'm sure my
friends will force me to play Call of
Duty zombies I'm Adam you're awesome
please leave a like if you can I'll see
you next time
[Music]
I wanted